on reste à moscou retrouver jean didier
revoir bonjour jean didier vladimir
poutine a donc mis ses menaces à
exécution cette nuit oui effectivement
il l'avait dit la reconnaissance des
républiques autoproclamées de donner
c'est de lougansk ouvrait la porte à une
opération militaire ici elle me trouve
beaucoup pensaient que cette opération
serait ils ont limité ou à la région du
donbass et ses alentours de façon à
venir en aide aux populations
russophones du temps de basse dont
vladimir poutine a dit à plusieurs
reprises qu'elle était victime d'un
génocide et ce matin ce qui a surpris
c'est l'ampleur de cette attaque qui
c'est qui ce qui atteint finalement
toutes les crèches ouvertes toutes les
villes importantes tous les points
militaires importantes ukrainien de
façon peut-être pour les russes à éviter
que l'armé crânienne puisse riposter à
ces activités dans de basses
effectivement l'armée ukrainienne évoque
à l'instant des combats en cours pour
une base militaire près de kiev
jean-didier est ce que les russes
soutiennent l'initiative de vladimir
poutine comment est-ce que cette annonce
a été accueillie disons que ce matin les
rues sont plus tôt sous l'effet de la
sidération il s'attendait bien
évidemment à une attaque des combats a
des difficultés mais comme je le disais
j'ai construite dans la région du
donbass il est sûr pendant ce matin
c'est l'ampleur de la tâche qui les
laisse plus ou mois assez sidéré et puis
c'est difficile de savoir quel est
l'impact qu'on aura vraiment cette
opération sur l'opinion publique parce
que un sondage récent qui doit remonter
week-end dernier faisait état de 73 %
des russes qui soutiennent la
reconnaissance des républiques
autoproclamées du donbass par l'admirent
poutine cinquante pour cent des russes
estiment même que moscou a le droit
d'empêcher kiev de rejoindre le temps
seulement 43 % des russes étaient contre
l'utilisation de la force pour annexer
l'ukraine alors ça c'est des propos qui
ont été tenus alors que l'idée d'une
guerre n'était que dans les esprits
maintenant que les hostilités ont bel et
bien commencé que les morts et les
blessés vont s'additionner
malheureusement au fil des jours eh bien
on ne sait pas dans quelle mesure la
population sera derrière cette opération
derrière avec mir comptines et si
finalement il n'y aura pas des
résistances alain terne pour essayer de
faire dévier vladimir poutine de son
objectif merci janvier rejoint en direct
de moscou